poursuit avec Véronique prouet les PDG
de manufacturiers exportateurs du Québec
bonsoir madame prou bonsoir donc je
présume c'est un soulagement de voir ce
conflit de travail touche à sa fin
absolument on est soulagé de voir que la
grève se termine alors et le père devant
couvert est loin de Montréal mais les
impacts étaient vraiment réels chez les
manufacturiers québécois et pour
l'économie québécoise donc c'est une
très bonne nouvelle et je tiens à
souligner le travail du médiateur des
deux parties du gouvernement fédéral qui
ont su faire en sorte qu'on arrive à un
entente aujourd'hui bon la
colombie-brise britannique comme vous le
dites c'est assez loin de nous mais
c'est important pour vos membres pour
les manufacturiers exportateurs du
Québec il y a donc des pertes qui seront
encourus et qui vont continuer d'être
encourus au cours des prochaines
semaines c'est ce qu'on comprend
absolument alors le père de Vancouver
c'est le port le plus achalandé au
Canada les entreprises québécoises
l'utilisent pour l'exportation vers
l'Asie mais aussi pour l'importation
dans le secteur de l'aérospatiale
automobile on peut parler à
l'agroalimentaire les biens de
consommation et j'en passe alors on a
fait on dévoilait aujourd'hui des
résultats d'un sondage pour mesurer
l'impact économique de cette grève là et
les manufacturiers en moyenne perdaient
135 000 dollars par jour par jour de
grève par entreprise alors c'est énorme
et pour chaque jour de grève on calcule
de 5 à 6 jours avant de reprendre un
cours normal donc on peut dire ce
concrètement c'est ça va prendre
plusieurs semaines avant que les
échanges commerciaux reprennent ça veut
dire quoi par exemple une entreprise
dont le conteneur est pris devant
couvert on en a plusieurs mais savent
pas encore à quel moment ils vont y
avoir accès et contenu de la congestion
tout au long autour du port ça pourrait
prendre plusieurs semaines avant qu'elle
récupère c'est la même chose pour les
entreprises qui ont la marchandise
qu'elle stockait pour exporter ça peut
prendre deux semaines trois semaines un
mois avant qu'elles aient accès aux
facilités portuaires pour pouvoir
exporter est-ce que ça peut donc
s'ajouter aux pertes dont vous parliez
c'est à dire on a des frais
d'entreposage supplémentaires par
exemple des frais d'entreposage des
pénalités lorsqu'on exporte on lève pas
attendre on a des contrats il y a des
pénalités importantes c'est des produits
qu'on n'est pas capable de vendre donc
sont pas capable d'être payé ça a un
impact sur notre fonds de roulement puis
à l'inverse à l'importation ben souvent
ce sont des produits qui sont très
critiques sont essentiels pour la
fabrication de certaines pièces
composantes donc certaines entreprises
ont ralenti leur chaîne de production
alors on va ressentir malheureusement
les effets encore pendant plusieurs
semaines et vous laissez entendre
justement dans votre publication
aujourd'hui que vous aimeriez qu'on
considère les activités de transport que
ce soit par train par navire les
installations portuaires comme un
service essentiel pourquoi absolument en
fait c'est le journée de la marmotte
pour les manufacturiers québécois si on
regarde au cours des dernières années on
a eu deux grèves au port de Montréal un
blocus ferroviaire une grève océenne
ULM basterbridge l'année dernière qui
avait été pris à partie par des
manifestants et loin de nous l'idée de
vouloir enlever le droit de manifester
mais ce sont toujours les
infrastructures de transport qui sont
prises qui sont prises par les
manifestants par les grévistes et c'est
les manufacturiers qui sont pris au
piège et j'ai envie de dire les
manufacturer mais aussi l'économie et
donc les consommateurs donc on dit au
gouvernement fédéral et on va travailler
avec eux au cours des prochaines semaine
prochains mois pour trouver une solution
structurante ça peut être de reconnaître
ces services là comme étant essentiel ça
peut être de faire certains changements
au cas du travail pour permettre au
ministre du Travail fédéral d'imposer
l'arbitrage sur le conflit devait durer
trop longtemps donc il faut trouver des
alternatives des mécanismes pour éviter
de se retrouver dans cette situation
mais en même temps vous avez en quelque
sorte d'expérience madame prouve vous me
nommiez tous les conflits qu'on a eu
dans les dernières années est-ce que les
manufacturiers exportateurs se sont pas
un peu adaptés il y a eu toutes sortes
de goulots d'étranglement aussi est-ce
que ce sont des des défis qu'on peut
surmonter ou desquels vous avez appris
en fait quand on regarde la grève au
port de Vancouver il y a pas beaucoup
d'autres alternatives pour les
exportateurs alors est-ce qu'on a appris
on a appris à résilient on a pris
peut-être à faire davantage de
provisions que ça occasionne des pertes
et ultimement ça fait qu'on est moins
compétitif par rapport à nos concurrents
internationaux et j'ai envie de dire
pour des entreprises étrangères qui ont
des opérations aux États-Unis par
exemple et au Canada ils se disent mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe au Canada c'est
un conflit après l'autre des relations
de travail qui font en sorte que ça a un
impact négatif sur les relations Canada
ou américaines par exemple bon à partir
de ce moment-ci au moins il y a de la
lumière absolument je vous remercie
beaucoup au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]